foreign
so thank you very much for joining today
and take it and taking the time to join
us for this conversation about digital
sovereignty
and how Google Cloud can help
organizations in Europe in supporting
there's already requirements
my name is Jurgen I'm a customer
engineer focusing on Sovereign digital
solutions for our customers
so I want to discuss today how we
understand digital sovereignty in
general at Google
and how we approach digital sovereignty
in the dark region
and then we will have an Outlook
uh on what we are also doing in the
European Union regarding digital
sovereignty
and after that as your developers and
practitioners
I will also tell some stories about uh
or give you some information what is
important to you and how to what's the
best practices are for handling digital
sovereignty
so then let's start by looking at how we
generally understand digital sovereignty
and then we take a special focus on the
offering we have currently in the dark
region
so organizations in the world
are using cloud services to drive the
innovation
so security scale sustainability and
Innovation offered by Cloud platforms is
well understood by customers
but often in discussions we hear that
they're wondering how can the balance
these benefits with their compliance and
sovereignty needs
so what is digital sovereignty
it depends very much whom you ask
there is no final definition
but we can describe it as the ability of
a state or an entity to regulate or
exert control over data and Technology
operating within its jurisdiction
and there is a growing demand for a
digital sovereignty that is rooted on a
number of concerns
and these are mostly not technically
reasons
and they include security and control
so the regulatory environment relating
to the cloud is very dynamic
and this is the overall trend in the
direction of global strategic economic
autonomy and digital sovereignty
and when we look especially in Europe
there's a strong desire to con to get
control of a cloud data and software
and this is also expanding globally
and as you know there are regulations
like gdpr
Signum cloud in France
and initiatives like Gaia X
and they're all
um are doing efforts to Define how Cloud
companies
operate
and run the infrastructure and how the
host workloads in Europe
and there are also on top of that
economic reasons
and there's a strong desire in several
countries to see local providers getting
involved in supporting some of these
initiatives in order to avoid for
example lock in or also to develop and
strengthen local economies
and yeah not to forget to get more
control over potential extra territorial
data access requests
and furthermore third Point geopolitical
demands
so policy makers technical leaders
business decision makers have an
interest in defining Sovereign policies
for their countries as I see more and
more data migrating from from a plane to
Cloud
and especially when we bring critical
National infrastructure to the cloud
there's always a concern or a question
of a degree of the degree which they can
trust the form cloud provider or not
bringing the sensitive data
to the cloud and and therefore they need
to have strong guidelines
and keeping these aspects in mind
we will also take Center look how we
already realized Cloud on Germany's
terms
and we will see which controls and
services there are available available
today
so now as we mentioned achieving digital
sovereignty can mean different things to
different people
but one common theme we can find is
control over your data so data is the
most important asset in the digital
world
and we ask Google believe having strong
controls is fundamental to meetings over
and requirements
in our main mind there are three
fundamental control objectives and these
are data residency personal controls and
encryption control
but but data controls are just one
element of a comprehensive digital
sovereignty approach
and that Google Cloud we serve for
broken it down in three very clear
pillars so the first pillar is data
sovereignty
so what to be mean to set
giving customers full control over their
core customer content their core
customer data and additionally we want
to provide the ability to store and
manage encryption keys outside of gcp
infrastructure
all done so that customers can protect
their data while still enjoying their
scale The Innovation and security of
public cloud
and on top of that the second pillar is
operational as opportunity
this gives the customer or a locally
trusted partner
control access or a direct visibility
on Google Cloud's operations
and I have also the ability to control
the access for support personnel
based on predefined attributes like
citizenship or
a particular geographic region
and this can enable more trust to to the
cloud provided with sensitive data
and last but not least there is software
sovereignty and this is often referred
also as job availability
and means protection against unforeseen
catastrophic events
and we believe that Google is that
software sovereignty and survivability
can only be accomplished with a modern
open Cloud approach
that is based on open source Solutions
and this is why Google has committed
very strongly to open Cloud and many of
our services of work our core cloud
services are based on open source
Technologies
so how can we achieve this at Google
yeah that there's a quite simple answer
with locally partners with the help of
local partners
and why we have already built a global
platform with many controls and
capabilities organizations can use to
meet their objectives for security
control and transparency
our goal is to be able to also deliver
localized portfolio for digital
sovereignty Solutions
by understanding the needs and
requirements for various countries and
by partnering very closely with trusted
local partners that help us to bring our
products to to the customers
so looking now at Germany
here we started a partnership with the
systems that are offering now Sovereign
controls for Germany in the dark market
and this is completely built on public
cloud
and there was a long-term partnership it
established last year between two
systems and Google to address a variety
variety of sovereignty needs in Germany
and this is going from data protection
deep supervision of cloud operations and
the capability to operate in also in
disconnected scenarios
so the product is called Sovereign
controls by T Systems and it provides
safeguards over gcp platform controls
and this is happening by the
implementation of data residency
controls locally support and operations
and external key management and access
control and accessory transparency
in the field trip your system will offer
additional controls like for identity
management and also as security
operations center
so looking into the data residency
controls
the systems ensures customer data can
only be stored in a German region
and also the services are restricted to
be deployed only in this region
by using a set of additional policies
but while still offering the integrated
experience of gcp
though this means customers will not see
a different
for example in the cloud console or
while using the services and consuming
apis it just feels like using gcp
foreign
function that is implemented with
Sovereign controls by t-systems is a
control of delivery and of support and
operations
that means support and operations access
are limited by underlying data access
controls and that's why I automatically
routed to the European Union persons
that are also located in in Europe
and additionally
the partner supervises access to
customer data by controlling the keys
needed to decrypt data so they
implemented a redundant external key
management system outside of gcp
infrastructure
so decrypting customer data always
requires a call outside of Google
infrastructure to get the externally
managed keys
and additionally the customer can expect
every request that is done to come with
a justification and the customer can
also block requests programmatically for
any reason
to get insights in this the partner
monitors access to get customer data and
configurations by using excess
transparency
the logs documented administrative
access to customer data providing to
systems and also the customer with an
audit trail of actions that have been
taken and the scope of the access
and there's an option to require
explicit approval before access to Great
customer data is granted
and the approvers can additionally be
signed with the customer keys to prove
it was really granted as a customer
and
Sovereign controls but his system is
available today and we are we are
starting the onboarding for the first
customers recently and currently there's
a bunch of services launched like TKE
cloud storage Cloud SQL and obviously
key management and logging what we need
for the solution itself
and there's it's hard work so it's a
long roadmap but we will launch more and
more services in the future in The
Sovereign controls product to offer more
and more services for digital
sovereignty over the time
so having seen what was happening in the
dark region
let's also take a look what is what
types of solution we can generally offer
in in the European Union
and how we have already started
implementing them in countries in the
European Union
for partners and customers here we can
offer three options
our Sovereign controls product allows
you to define the location of your core
data who has access to the query data
and the control of cryptographic keys
by the way we think without all these
technical con or three technical
controls you don't have data sovereignty
and additionally the customer can choose
to apply gcp's core platform control
such as DLP to dnt5 data or confidential
Computing to encrypt data while it is in
use
then on top of that we have the part
partner management partner managed
Sovereign Solutions
um that it's the ability to to the
partner to Monitor and control Google
access to data providing both visibility
and control over operational elements
and our supervised Cloud offering then
available in the future will be fully
managed and operated by Partners
supporting data and operational
sovereignty needs for specialized and
highly sensitive data
and lastly
for situations where there is a strong
need to have less Reliance on the
software provider
our hosted Cloud offering will support
software sovereignty and allow for air
Captain disconnected operations without
provider software or support
and we do this in Europe in conjunction
with a very trusted Partners so I talked
already about these systems but we
started already an initiative in France
together with Tales we founded a
joint venture that is called SARS to
offer Cloud on Europe Europe's terms for
French customers
and yesterday I think in the Keynotes we
also announced new Partnerships in Italy
and Spain
the offering is called local controllers
by source and is now available in
preview and builds also on Google public
cloud services
it supports and the requirements for
data residency Access Control locally
support
and builds a foundation for Sovereign
workloads in France
so sober entities in a connected world
is not an easy task
but I think we as Google have understood
it's important
and we have engaged in a long journey to
deliver this
so cloud of of Europe terms as a set of
carefully tailored Solutions put
together with local partners
to preserve the original value of Google
Cloud
but deliver in a way that is acceptable
for our Global customers starting with
Europe
and having seen what is happening in the
dark region in Europe regarding digital
sovereignty I want to talk now about
what topics are important to know for
you and interesting as a practitioner or
developer
so first Sovereign controls is not a
fork of gcp
it has the same code base and it offers
you and the customer integrated
experience
it builds on the known public cloud
services
and you can use and develop all the
tools that you already know
the apis are aren't aren't unchanged
and if you look at automation
you can deploy the whole infrastructure
with terraform or similar tools and if
you have existing scripts today you can
just reuse them
and what we see is a big chance for
innovation
so Sovereign controls and this our
Sovereign Cloud efforts give you as a
developers a basis to create compliant
Solutions
depending on the customer's needs using
services that you already know
to finish it up I want to talk about
some best practices and considerations
so first
understand the customers or your
workload requirements
so one solution will never fit it all
and it's important to distinguish and
understand what is needed for your use
case your application and the data
involved
that will prepare you to make the right
trade-offs when it comes to choosing
Technology Solutions
and there is a chance I was very often
talking about Sovereign topics with
customers in the last months there's a
big chance that the customer thinks or
the business unit thinks everything must
be in in a sovereign environment and if
you look at the data in the use case
itself you will always find that only a
part of this data needs Sovereign
Solutions and the distinct other part
might still run simply on public cloud
and second think about yeah how Hands-On
you want to be regarding operations
understanding how to plan and manage
operational complexity is key to
deciding how to handle sovereignty with
your cloud provider and whether it may
make it a visit may make sense to work
with a trusted third party
and lastly think Global think big think
about your business needs for the future
to understand the right path for your
digital transformation Journey
I am currently also working with
customers that have requirements
regarding sovereignty in France and in
Spain and in Germany and then it's
getting starting to be interest very
interesting yeah keep this in mind
so thank you very much for your
attention I will be around for questions
and we are happy to discuss with you
and we have a break now before the
change
and after this after the break I think
we have the productivity
Works developer workstations session
by Alexis
thank you very much
[Music]